[Música]
foi bom dia
hoje vou começar com vocês sobre o
assunto muito importante que a obesidade
infantil
escolhi esse tema porque eu sempre me
preocupei muito com a saúde alimentar
das pessoas em minha a verdade não é um
problema que só corre aqui no brasil é
uma epidemia mundial que atinge todas as
classes gêneros e idades
problemas como colesterol alto diabetes
que eram mais vistas em adultos
agora a gente pode perceber nas crianças
o que pode ser um grande prejuízo na
saúde delas
mas para modificar o nosso futuro
precisamos voltar para o passado para
entender por que as modificações
ocorreram essa imagem da minha avó
amy cantou que antigamente as pessoas
fazem seus próprios alimentos como olho
de massa de bolo
atualmente as pessoas já não fazem mais
os próprios elementos
elas preferem comprar já pronto xixi
carboidratos e gorduras
agora vou mostrar pra vocês um vídeo que
eu mesmo fiz sobre alguns alimentos que
a gente costuma comer no dia a dia
[Música]
ei ei que tinha ganhado tanto aqui e
olha agora é o baixinho aqui no flamengo
[Música]
e farinha
i e ii
simplesmente não é
a obesidade não dá relacionada com os
alimentos que a gente costuma comer mas
também quando tivesse que a gente
costuma fazer por exemplo antigamente as
pessoas escreviam cartas para se
comunicar com os outros e gastavam mais
energia fazendo as atividades do dia a
dia
atualmente as coisas ficaram muito mais
cômodas por exemplo play no supermercado
a gente simplesmente chama o motorista
pela web antes as crianças brincam mais
ao ar livre e gastavam mais energia em
espaços maiores mas hoje em dia elas se
referem a seu tempo jogando videogame
assistindo televisão e mexendo no
celular
além disso também tem o problema da
propaganda infantil que influencia o que
essas crianças irão consumir
agora vocês já sabem que temos que nos
alimentar melhor e fazer mais atividades
para termos um futuro mais saudável
o que posso dizer para vocês hoje é que
façam suas escolhas
muito obrigada pela sua atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]